voicing billing whatever your crm system
handles all your customer contacts
marketing campaigns and so forth
and the e-commerce system is your web
shop or
online services and other things you
need
now you want to build a web app for your
sales team they want a simple way of
viewing their order status and history
and use that while talking to their
customers
now all of these systems have different
apis on top of them
they're like different sized lego blocks
if you ever
got that present from your grandmother
that bought somewhere
that they had that bought micro blocks
or something which
looks like lego but is not it doesn't
fit
and you had all this nice lego and
wooden fit and it was mismatched and you
were like
thanks grandma throw this straight away
they're not really compatible they're
different
different ways of interacting with
different ways of querying but
we're going to assume a happy life here
and when they
at least they have defined some apis for
you to use you don't have to go sifting
through an old database with four little
tape
that are table names so we have this web
app
that has different parts that's one
store status for the orders history
customer view and all of these
things need access to different kinds of
data in one or more services
and the project is delivered and was
delivered as a tremendous success
sure it took a while to develop these
integrations
but it was budgeted for the project was
delivered on time
it was under budget everyone was happy
in fact
the sales team is so pleased that they
want something similar but not quite the
same
in a mobile app because they're often on
the road and they need this information
so they wanted some more features as
well and there's a different context so
we can't really reuse everything and it
wasn't really a topic when you were
building the web app
which is an asp.net and the mobile app
wants to be built in react native
so we can't really reuse a lot of the
stuff here so we redo a lot of the work
and they all know that this is not ideal
but there are constraints
there's time constraints budget and
there's that consultant that was in here
for six months doing the last app and
he's out so nobody knows what that
happened
no long-term thinking and over change
over time
change becomes very difficult and as we
all know the only thing we can rely on
being constant
is change in this business and this is
just a simple example
if you had a few more back-end services
and a bunch more apps you'll quickly see
that this is not really a desirable
situation
this is the kind of stuff that makes mr
newman sad
he's also named the world's most sad dog
the world's saddest dog
so what does any business want
more of today except money everyone
wants more money but the next best thing
that done
money is things that let you make more
money
faster and that's usually three things
there's innovation we want to have the
options to innovate we want to
experiment we want to try
new things we want to fail fast heard
that expression
does this work if it doesn't tweak a
little bit how does it work now
and people are i want to operate on the
mantra that if you're standing still
you're falling behind
in order to have that you need to have
some form of agility
doesn't it work well change it try
something else
put this out there do an experiment get
feedback
tweak something show it out there again
and iterate on top of that
embrace change heard that expression
before it's really hard to explain
embrace change when you're dealing with
that three-letter german
and you want speed you want to reduce
the time to market you want to see
something happening
respond to that you want to react to
your competitors even better
you want to be ahead and beat them so
they can react to you instead
all of these things are hard to do when
you're working directly on top of a
back-end system
even in the best of cases like our
example what we need to do is to build
this capability
outside the backend systems and on top
of them
and there's perfectly good reasons why
we can't have all those things in our
back-end systems
you do not want people tinkering with
erp or payroll system every day and
optimizing that for customer
satisfaction
we want to optimize those system for
stability and safety
but we also want these other things so
what we do
is that we make two lanes make a slow
lane for stability
and a fast lane for innovation and
experimentation
this is where our api comes in it
divides those systems
between those two lanes but also enables
how the communication between those two
modes of thought or modes of speed
and i'm on i pretend to be an engineer
so i
brought data to back my statements up
not much but there's two case studies
from usof did which is
considering the source real soft makes
api systems
but they implement in company apis in
siemens they were 50
faster twice as fast when delivering
their mvps
which means that you can get those
experiments going a lot faster
bp two times faster app development that
cuts your development costs in half
because most of the cost is personnel
which is a significant impact so there's
not
this is not something you might want to
do because it's technically nicer it
actually can have real business value
and real
speed value in your your company
so how do we do this well we're going to
need some tools and we're going to need
some process or some
a direction so we're going to start from
the bottom and work our way up
the basic problem we're struggling with
here is that all our back-end services
have their own language
and as the tower of babel story that
makes it impossible to communicate
properly
and is really hard to build on top of
that
the cool thing about these conferences
is that there's a lot of people from
different parts of the world that come
together
i've been to conferences where we had a
group with people from sweden from
netherlands the uk
us canada romania uh it was an israeli
guy there
and we could all talk together and as
we're doing right now
because we spoke to common language
english in our case we decided that
that's what we're going to speak
everybody knows that and
we're going to communicate on that
and that's what we need we need a common
way of communicating with the other
services
a single language not a programming
language
more of a language of definitions a
language of how to describe a system
so that other systems can understand our
description
so we need some kind of way of
describing these systems
open api is one of those languages or
description format
open api can describe an http based api
which means a web service
it allows you to describe your api your
endpoints your operation
responses parameters the lot it used to
be called swagger
some might remember that name that's
renamed and rebranded as open api
the important part is that it's machine
readable
it has a structure to it that can be
interpreted relatively easily by a
machine
it can be adjacent or yaml if you
depending on
what you want or how big a fan you are
of significant white space
some of you dylan might be old enough to
remember whistle files
which is sort of the same thing and you
can say a lot of bad things about soap
but whistle files was not one of those
bad things
they were kind of cool you pointed at
whistle file boom there's your client
now don't worry if this is hard to read
or it seems obscure
you're not really supposed to read it
but we're going to take a quick a little
close look at some parts of it
here's an end point slash users within
loud operation you can get
it could have been post but in this case
it's get
it can respond with a 200 okay that's
good
and it can return some an array of
strings
and right above that it says it's
application jc
so these parts here describe an endpoint
slash user we can do a get
call it's no parameter is defined it
will respond with a 200 and then it will
give you json
with an array of strings that
information
is enough to generate clients
there can be a lot more information in
here that will enable you to generate
more
information but you can consume that
description file from various tools and
automatically generate clients from
various languages
you can for instance generate both a c
sharp client and a typescript client
from the same open api file
the open api file can include
information like the
type names field names
and so on and so forth our example was
super simple
but it will allow you to generate a full
set of
types classes apis
methods that are named intelligently
because you have made some effort in the
to start with right
now there's lots of tools for doing this
in various languages and
the actual generation is not as
interesting in this context
the important thing here to know is that
open api
can be used to generate clients
automatically
what is interesting we're going to look
a little bit up is
different ways of generating the open
api file
from a service the details are different
in various languages
but the generals uh the general
themes are similar in the dot-net world
there's
three or two two three major options of
generating your file
depending on the definition of
generating
one option is adding code your
application it will generate an open api
file
in this case we're using um swashbuckle
i think the api is called
and there's two major ones on.net
swashbuckle and ends flag
where you add a swagger generator
which will register an open api
generator that inspects your routes your
properties parameters
methods classes and generates an open
api specification
on top of that then a little further
down
you can insert your middleware that
allows you to
that will output your json file or
swagger file and you can also register a
ui part
which will give you a ui for your
swagger file or your open api definition
it's usually a tool that lets you
examine and play with the api i'm gonna
do a
short look at that
this one of our services we have
currently it looks like this there's uh
different endpoints grouped by
controller so we have a my page we have
notifications payment and there's a
bunch of work well
on this particular server you can expand
those you can see whatever parameters
they need this one doesn't need any no
parameters
scrolling down you can see different
responses it can do this one will return
a 200 success
it will return an object with uh
three strings to it or an array of
objects with three strings in each
a type a form id and a status
it can return a form one unauthorized or
four or three forbids this describes
the different expectations a client can
have from this endpoint
top right there's a try it out button
clicking that will
allow you to execute your api it will
actually do a call against your api
you can see the uh a curl example that
you could use from the command line
or terminal and you get a response body
and response headers
this one returned three items
and some response headers so it's a
really super easy way to explore an api
api and get a feel for what it does
without having to ask albert down in the
basement who manages the erp system
what all those four level tape letter
table names actually mean
the other way is inspecting your
compiled assembly
looking at the code basically
decompiling your assembly
looking at that and generating the open
api document from that
the advantage here is that you can do
this with an existing application
without
actually changing any code redeploying
anything
it has various degrees of success
depending on how your
application is compiled but it is it can
be a really useful
avenue it usually requires more tweaking
and config files and you can do
i'll have a little bit less options but
it's perfectly viable options especially
to get started
easily with existing code the
third way is to go the other way
is to start by crafting your open api
document there's lots of tools online
that lets you do this
easier than just writing yaml or json
yourself
and then you can use that document to
generate the api
this has several advantages because
there are some things in the standard
that is not easily expressible
for a swatch buckle and and tools like
that to pick up
but this is not really talk about open
api so if you want to learn more about
that
those things read more about it i
suggest the microsoft docs pages
or the open apis uh
now assuming we have a bunch of open api
in place let's go back to our three
services
where should we start well we'll make
sure we have an open fbi interface on
top of each service
most major legacy systems or enterprise
systems
do not offer this today it's gonna come
they're gonna be better at it but right
now they don't
if they do that's super
so let's make an open api service on top
of these you wanna probably wanna start
with query operations
but eventually these things will evolve
pretty much into correct operations
so how do we do this well we can make
small micro services
that expose an api and proxy those calls
down to the backend system
so each system here would have one or
several microservices could have
depending on the context and
and domains and there's also various
tools that can talk to different
enterprise systems
and legacy apis and expose an open api
depending on your environment and you
where you're at you can do this with
little or no code
let's do it look at a small example for
instance azure logic apps
which is a no code solution which where
you can
define connectors and data between them
uh favorite tool of the economy guy in
my company he loves logic apps
and they have a pre-built sap connector
you define your input send a message sap
define your output
and it will automatically generate an
open api file that you can consume from
somewhere else
but it can really be anything that's
able to talk to your backend system
and respond to an http request so logic
apps is a nice no code solution
it could also be a bespoke web
application running somewhere
it could be some serverless functions it
could be a bunch of orchestrated
microservice containers
running in a dual distributed kubernetes
cluster whatever you want
or just plain old virtual machines it
doesn't really matter the important
thing here
is to establish a common way of
discovering and interfacing with these
services
http apis documented by open api
and to get that you do whatever you have
to do to make that work for the
different kinds of services
get that open api on top here
now we have that foundation going we
have our different
backend systems and we have an open api
interface on top of that
through some kind of service or some
kind of solution or benefits
what you do not want to do is eat the
whole elephant at once
you do not sit down and look at your
whole range of backend systems and okay
let's start on the left
and then we'll drive through here and
get
all these things done you build what you
need
when you need it perhaps we're building
a front end that needs to display some
information about a customer but that
information is spread across two
back-end systems
so working with the demands around
customer information we build
two services one for the erp system
and one for the crm system
these services only cover a small part
of the underlying system
small vertical slice if you want we do
not
expose the entire erp system which would
be a huge undertaking
just the little part that we need for
that particular project
and then as a new project comes along
that we'll take another part and then
another part and then we move along
like that and we can build more services
on top of this combining several
services
so customer information is often spread
across
different systems some information in
that system some information that system
we never really know so we can get a
common view here
and say this is what a customer looks
like we establish that as a fact
what we're doing now is that we're
establishing a company-wide ubiquitous
language
saying what does this mean what does a
customer contain
what does when i use this word what does
that mean
in all these different contexts
depending on where it comes from
so the erp system and crm system might
have different names
for the same actual data and
moving up in the stack we can make this
the same names
so and then we can build more services
that can consume a nice unified data
from our customer service
without having to care about how these
underlying systems are structured
it doesn't matter anymore it just says
here's a customer we have defined
what a customer looks like in our
company and that's all the order history
has to care about
and then we can build more servers on
top of that again
so all of these top layers except for
the blade for the bottom layer
all of these tops are an open api
surface easily consumable
so this building these apis becomes
relatively easy compared to what it used
to be the grunt work here is now done
and the work involved in building
clients on top of this here
that's also reduced greatly you can get
a c-sharp client generated from the web
api
make web pages you can get a react
native mobile app that
consumes the mobile api with typescript
client
both clients will have strongly typed
data objects strongly typed api clients
making it super easy to consume these
apis and whatever data they have
and now we get that speed and agility
part
an innovation where you say okay what if
we had this thing i don't know
let's build a small prototype and find
out if it helps
and but isn't that hard no we just
consume some api throw up a mock-up and
a little extra experiment and there we
are
and we can also start layering our cake
here at the bottom
there's a data layer then we have a
persistence layer there
here you need insight and knowledge
about the underlying system
on top that's where we define our
ubiquitous language one thing means the
same across the entire company
there's not customer first name customer
surname customer given name anymore it's
just
we define the customers have first name
that's it
the business layer now you don't have to
know
the underlying systems anymore how they
work
here you need knowledge about the actual
business and this processes the
ubiquitous language goes here right
who owns what what happens if this goes
on and so on and so forth these are the
business processes
we are now abstracted away from the ugly
underbelly of the beast
which is the three-letter german and his
friends
and we have some form of presentation
layer where you combine several sources
into views
specialized for each app a client or
domain or situation or context
this can be done by client by client
basis or you can have some relatively
standard ones
it doesn't really matter it's up to you
and your situation
but for instance a mobile app you might
want to send less data over the wire so
you're going to drop a few fields and
skip some resources
than you would in a different kind of
app if you're a graphql fan
this is where you'd put that endpoint as
well maybe crossing down a little bit
down in the business layer because
you can do a little bit more that
depending on your complexity
and your your
actual needs but then you would have
graphql
endpoint which would consume different
open open api services
and then could be used for your mobile
app your web app and whatever
it's very helpful to think of your api
in terms of these layers because these
layers have different characteristics we
talked about how they have different
knowledge needs
but they also have different
characteristics
velocity and agility will increase as
you go up the stacks
the top is where you do your innovation
your experimentation
you change things around you try a
little bit here you try a little bit
there
as you're moving down again things
become more rigid
but instead of having that hard border
which you crossed immediately before
there's a gradient you can have
different levels of agility
this enables the things we talked about
speed innovation
agility it also enables things like
autonomous teams where teams can be more
self-sufficient
more self-organizing saying that oh we
want to in
your business somewhere they can
sit down have a couple of smart
developers
or super users even with no code
solutions which can
easily consume open api like powerapps
and say oh what if we have this and this
and this and combine this and show it
this way
do you think that would help us i don't
know let's try and find out and
a team somewhere in the corner of your
company can do that experiment without
having to involve
a whole bunch of chain up and chained
down in two different departments and
albert in the basement
now this can easily look complicated
even if these boxes have the same
surface
on top and if you leave it as purely
individual parts
it will get complicated and complex next
move here is to try to make this into
more of a unified surface which can be
controlled
um in the orderly fashion
this is what's called api management api
management is having a tool or a service
of some kind that helps us with most of
the things we talked about
this could be a homegrown kubernetes
platform
that you have a whole bunch of
governance
and procedures and helper tools to
put your stuff into it and make it
that is fine i know several companies
who have built that themselves
um
these this api management there's also
different tools that will do a lot of
this for you
what they'll do more specifically is
they will connect your backend systems
they will expose them as open apis they
can do translations from one standard to
another you can combine multiple apis
into one
and most of these things are done
through configuration not necessarily
development
which if you manage to keep yourself
within the box a tool like that offers
can give you a lot of speed and
flexibility
within that framework it also does a
few more things that makes it worth
looking at
such as authentication authorization
you can handle that at the edge of your
api and you don't really have to care
about it going further in
providing your your system is correctly
set up you can do
that off in the begin at the edge and
any service further in
can just assume that that thing is
handled
you can do rate limiting making sure
that nobody screws up and hammers your
erp system
100 times per second
you can do analytics how your api is
being used
what's not being used what can be
deprecated what can we
remove what do we really need to uh to
keep
when you do caching there's in this
any company there's lots of data which
are almost static that never really
changes much
there's no need to hit the backing
system for all those requests we can
cache those at the edge
it also makes more performant clients
instead of going all the way down to the
four letter tables in the database
so how would that look well
we'll take a brief look at a system that
one particular product that i know
which is azure api management there are
several products out there i mentioned
mulesoft earlier they
create a project a product that does a
lot of this
i'm going to talk about azure api
management because that's the one i'm
familiar with
but they all have the this is several
different ones out in the market
what you do with api management is you
import an existing api you have to have
somewhere
that you can read data for it from
because it doesn't have data on its own
it will connect to different several
different sources including open api
when importing you specify a path to
your specification file to your json
file
point to that file and then it will
iterate through that
like we looked at it will find the
endpoints find the operations
and it will list all the different
operations that you have
or that it found there's uh some
api for a conference tool those are all
the operations defined in the
backend's open api specification
hopefully supported by the backend as
well
what you can do next is that you can add
what's called policies or processing
you can add policies to both inbound and
outbound processing
to modify both the request and the
response
there's lots of things you can do here
but a policy is a definition of things
you want to happen
or check on the way in or out
you can set http headers you can search
and replace
text in the request or response you can
set rate limits you can
hide fields add fields combine multiple
apis into one
you can have multiple policies that are
executed sequence you can have logic and
control flow
you can respond to errors and
this becomes a really powerful low code
tool to gather and define your apis you
can
even add c sharp code in here depending
on your backend system
this could cover both the presentation
the business layer and perhaps even down
to your data
layer depending on what you the backend
system looks like
for instance if you have a backend
system that
is has a soap api
which is not easily consumable from a
javascript application for instance you
azure api management can automatically
convert between a soap api
to a rest or http based api api
it has a developer portal which is
really useful for larger organizations
where you as an administrator can define
your apis you bundle them into products
and users can sign up for those products
this can be open to everyone if you're
that kind of shop
it can be subject to approval or
lockdown with azure id
and a user could go in and start a
subscription to
one or more products they can see the
documentation for the api
pulled from the open api file pretty
much like we saw
earlier from the swatch buckle ui but
same kind of
thing but in a different place try out
the api from the browser
just like one would expect to use with
an open api
system they can self-subscribe to
products
manage their own subscription keys again
this is very beneficial to autonomous
teams
it's self-service no few or no
bottlenecks
so a team can decide oh we want to we
have an application there it would be
really helpful if we had access to
that kind of data well let's go into the
management portal and see what's there
and you can find okay here's an api it
looks too
looks useful right take it can take a
look at it
yeah this will give us what we want to
register
subscribe to it get a subscription key
you're off to the races
know when an it needs to be involved you
don't have to talk to
anyone to get access or different
passwords
if you've done your work right
everything is still access controlled
and nobody has to bother albert down in
the basement with his
four-level letter tables anymore there's
much more to api management i could do a
whole talk just about that but
that's going to be another session maybe
next year
but know that these kinds of tools exist
and they can be really powerful for
getting
quickly up and running with something
whether you use that tool or you build a
bespoke thing with lots of microservices
you now end up with a unified surface
for your enterprise
this too has an open api surface making
it easy for those us to consume this
api in our apps now
if you're making your own backend
systems you have your own baseball
back-end system for doing
domain-specific things don't forget to
import those
into your api gateway as well offer
open api services add them to your api
layer
it will remove some work for you like
caching rate limiting authentication
but it can also make your stuff and data
available to the rest of the company
your standard and open easily consumable
interface
which can enable collaboration and
innovation that you maybe you didn't
think about
think of before
one important thing to remember or
figure out is
who owns what data what particular piece
of data is owned by who
and not just who owns the customer but
who owns the registration date for the
customer who owns the address
the name different fields
because in a system a large company
this information the unified customer
view is going to be spread
on different systems and there's going
to be duplication
if you have a customer that has an
address that's probably present both in
the erp system for work orders
and the crm system for for customer
follow-ups
and account management
who owns the address right
this is what's known as master data
management and
can in many companies be a really really
hard problem
if you have multiple systems you're
going to have duplication and you need
to know what is the primary source
if you don't know what the primary
source is what source is defined as a
master or
always correct you have a hard time
giving a trustworthy source to the rest
of your company
also if you're going to take updates you
really need to have this figured out
because up to now we only talked about
querying what happens when we put want
to put data back
into the system well there's several
ways of doing that as well
and what you end up with will be based
on your environment
and your systems but there's
three main ways of doing this
one let the customer server sort it out
customer service already knows where
it's pulling the various pieces from
it's not a huge leap to let it know
where to put what back
it knows that the erp has the
uh address but the crm customer has the
email address for instance
and it will take those data put it there
take that data put that there
take an update update different systems
accordingly
the other option is to decouple the
customer service with updating downwards
what it will do instead is send out an
event we'll pick that up
some kind of message bus or transport or
service bus or whatever but somewhere
that can put a
pull up message and can forward that to
different subscribers
so both the erp and the crm customer
services are interested in customer
updates
they get their updates delivered and
then
they will update further down as needed
we can also send updates to different
systems
that are not our backend system to let
them know what happened which can be a
powerful addition to an api system
having on some kind of event driven bus
that
various systems can connect into
the uh many enterprise systems also have
eventing systems built in
and they can notify when information is
changed
from that system it's not a given that
every update has to go through your api
wall from the different apps these erp
systems the crm systems they have their
own powerful interfaces
and updates are going to happen there as
well so you need to figure out
when something is updated in those
systems how do we make sure that
data duplication doesn't occur or master
data
is correct this is a task you've
probably been doing already if you have
these systems because you
you have that data separate
but they have their own inventing
systems that can
propagate information these are
you also have the traditional ways of
these systems interacting
which are database copies flat file
exchanges
imports exports and so on and so forth
which version you want will depend on
what kind of model you're most
comfortable with
how much logic is involved and showing
things into the back end
and we're not going to talk about how to
build an event system that's slightly
out of scope
but i'm happy to talk to anyone who's
interested in them after
the talk
so where do you start what are where
where do you go from here
if you're writing any apis today make
sure you have open api files from
if you're making a system that has data
that should be shared or could be shared
between the
within the company and it has an api
make an open api interface it is not
hard it's not a lot of work
and it'll make a lot easier to integrate
your system later
even if you're not using it for anything
else
now that you have the first building
block
fill that eight open api proxy if you
talk to a back-end system
so if you're having an application that
today is talking to
on a back-end system which is kind of
weird or
odd to talk with doesn't have an open
api interface
make that proxy it's a small sliver of
an application
if you're making a web application or
similar you can even build it into the
application just make it a separate part
and now you have a start you have that
building block going
it is important not to
chew over too much struggle what you
need
base your building on business needs
business says we need this data okay
where is that good here's that piece of
data
we're going to take this data and expose
and build on top of that
don't sit six months building a huge
proxy and
not going to need 80 of it
i suggest you do a proof of concept with
a cloud managed api gateway or some
management tool
it is dead cheap to get started figure
out easy
figure out quickly is this something for
us will this help us
it makes it really easy to get a
structure and a governance in place
early when you have a small number of
apis
and then instead of coming into a chaos
and then trying to
lay some governance on top of that later
and master data management it is super
important if you don't know who owns
what data there's no way of trusting
that
the data you output and give on unto
others
that's it for me um
feel free to reach out either on twitter
or email if you have any follow-up
questions coming up
uh or later any shower thoughts that
come to mind in a
later occasion if anyone has
anything they're wondering about right
now then
go right ahead excellent stuff glenn
thank you
and yes folks please unmute yourselves
if you have
questions we can have actual discussion
going on here
in the mysterious online world of
digital conferences
um i thought that was really good and uh
thank you so much for
for speaking and being part of it all
question from matt in the chat
having api management does not lead to a
single point of failure
uh sure just as having one layer piece
this erp system leads to a single point
of failure
um having uh
api management um
if you're going for azure api management
is a hosted service that is pretty well
uh distributed and has all the it's not
a box
uh sitting there so and the same rules
follow
if you want to make your stuff highly
available then you invest in making it
highly available you have separately you
have double
machines and do all that stuff
if you have you basically have a cluster
if you want to run
mulesoft or something like that
internally you don't install that on a
single machine you install it on a
bigger machine
yes you get you gather all your eggs in
one basket and then you
make that basket as robust as you need
from a business standpoint
and this is of course a trade-off
between
never having downtime and paying all
your money to do to manage that
did that answer your question matt
we're gonna assume it did it did awesome
any other questions folks
all right well we're keeping track one
open because in about 15 minutes
we're going to be closing out the
conference here with some
you